this week we've been showing you what
it's like to be Donny Osmond does our
Donnie wheat continues you know he's
been a part of Las Vegas for so long he
almost feels like family to many of us
but it's his real family he told me to
keeps him grounded and yes he even does
house chores
you're part of the fabric of this
community yes and this community has
been through a lot no doubt yes what
does it mean to you well I've seen this
town
kind of like my career of the ups and
downs and in betweens
I've seen this town when it was
considered a ghost town for
entertainment
[Applause]
get the world what's beautiful about
Vegas right now is that it's better than
ever before and Donnie is loving it when
you ask me about the importance of Las
Vegas
it really is the creme de La Creme in in
Show Business my wife and I love being
nevadans right now
Entertainer extraordinaire is done it
all and now he's raking in the accolades
for his solo show but it's his family he
says that keeps him rooted and when I go
home I take out the garbage mow the lawn
to stuff like that married 44 years
Donnie remembers the moment he knew she
was the one as I was dating a girl by
the name of Tammy and Jay was dating my
wife Debbie we went to an Elton John
concert and when when Elton sat down
it's a little bit funny he was singing
your song I remember looking over at my
brother's date thinking I'm going to
marry that girl someday and two weeks
about two weeks after that double date
we switched he says it's all about
balance because to him family still
comes first just had our 13th grand baby
so life is great and I don't want to
lose that
it seems like he's got it all he's
certainly loving it we love having him
as a resident here he says he bought a
house in Sunderland our